if a Donald Trump became president he
couldn't he didn't he doesn't have the
executive authority to suddenly create a
police surveillance state that has no
checks on it whatsoever I think that's
very important so you wouldn't want
Donald Trump to have a kill list right
but Obama he's no look I think I I think
that you need we need safeguards in
place and I think that the judiciary is
one place to do I think judiciary is
probably the only place to do that
because I don't think you can open
everything up to the public because you
just you can't you can't have on
national security all the time full
transparent but also at you know on
transparency that was another bedrock
campaign principal right being rice
transparent administration and during
his administration he's prosecuted more
whistleblowers than any other previous
administration the number of classified
documents has exploded where do you
think he went off the rails on that
respect only thing I only think I would
say is and I I'm only saying this
because my friends who worked in the
national security decided to say it I
don't know enough to comment on it as
much but over-classification is a huge
problem too many things are classified
just because and I think the president
has recognized that problem as well so I
think that's something that you need to
do the whistleblower thing I have to say
when you sign up and you decide that
you're going to be part of the federal
government especially if you get a
security clearance they tell you if you
leak information it is a severe penalty
and and very very illegal and if you
don't want to and if you feel like
you're conscious is going to stop you
then don't sign up and don't get your
security clearance and go find another
job those people have to be prosecuted
because it's part of the law and so this
whole thing so far journalists haven't
been prosecuted about this right the
people who were the administration has
gone after the people who have broken
the law by leaking highly sensitive
national security information but they
were tapping journalists phones and I
mean they're you know there was that
like Eric Holder subpoenaed records from
journalists and I mean right well when
you can't deny that he has no because
you any other press once you get well
there's just been more there's just been
more leaks that's why you know like I
don't there's I'm for sure the President
did not walk
and say I gotta clamp down on all these
whistleblowers it's just the case has
come to the Justice Department because
someone both along and there was a leak
and sensitive classified information and
we have to have an investigation and
part of the investigation is they told
this journalist right so then that's
when records are subpoenaed and all that
kind of stuff you know I think it is
fair that you say that there's this law
you break the law you should be
prosecuted but at the same time you know
everybody's their sworn to uphold the
Constitution as well and yeah somebody
like Thomas Drake who tried you know
numerous numerous times going up the
chain wasn't taken seriously and that's
when he went to the press same thing you
know Edward Snowden he claims that he
went up the chain several times yeah so
do you think that there's any role for
civil disobedience when you are
convinced that the Constitution is being
violated which has now been affirmed by
federal courts and nobody's doing
anything about it look I think that's a
tough I think that's a tough question i
think inside i guess i would answer it i
don't know i think i think there's I
think there's a role for I do think
there's a role for civil disobedience of
course and I think there's a role for
whistleblowers in our society of course
but I do think that there are there are
also you know like I said there's a lot
so there's laws on the book and there
are roles for there's a role for civil
disobedience and beyond that like I
don't I don't know enough about every
single case to be spouting off left and
right but I at the point is well taken
but you think he's generally unbalanced
treated I dish you idly I do